dieser nachgeschmack bombe dritte
segment erst mal weiß man sich durch
einen extrem lockeren mandl boden mit
dieser superweichen bestreben diese
leichten temperamente kommt noch die
sagt kick einfach das
regenrisiko wissen sie ist auch
eigentlich ist der komplette rückraum
diskutieren harmonie hochziehen hallo
ihr lieben und willkommen zu einem ganz
besonderen video wir machen heute eine
cocos torte beziehungsweise anna rafaela
korte und warum dieses video so
besonders für mich ist das werdet ihr im
laufe des videos schon sehen ich werde
euch die ganz genauen mengenangaben wie
immer hier unten in die infobox
schreiben und wir starten jetzt direkt
mit unserem boden aus nur vier zutaten
[Musik]
also ich sage jetzt erst mal die eier in
einer schüssel ihr könnt natürlich auch
eine küchenmaschine verwenden aber ich
wollte euch in diesem video zeigen dass
ihr eigentlich auch nur ein
handrührgerät benötigt so eier in die
schüssel da dann zucker mit dazugeben
und dann mit dem handrührgerät zwei bis
drei minuten lang aufschlagen so dass
die masse richtig schön hell cremig wird
und danach höre ich nur noch gemahlene
mandeln und backpulver unter
[Musik]
der teig ist schon fertig also ein vier
minuten teig und er ist so themen frei
für alle die sich gut ernähren und jetzt
kommt der tat mit dem tortenring ihr
könnt auch eine springform mit 20
zentimetern durchmesser verwenden habe
ich ja auch da aber dadurch dass ich
gleich noch mal den tortenring drumherum
mache mache ich mir nicht zwei dinge
schmutzig und geben dafür einfach nur
den tortenring und dafür nehmen wir uns
ein backpapier jetzt hier schon die 20
cm eingestellt und dann knicken wir das
backpapier immer an den rand des rings
und so haben wir den tortenring quasi
eingeschlagen und dann kann auch nichts
aus laufen aber unser tag sowieso ein
bisschen fest also läuft ja sowieso
nichts aus
[Musik]
ihr müsst den tag auch gar nicht
verstreichen einfach ein bisschen
schütteln und dann verteilt er sich
automatisch und der kommt jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen 180 grad ober und
unterhitze dabei auch der teig 26
minuten und danach werde ich den nach
dem backen direkt einmal am rand lösen
dadurch dass wir keinen mehr haben ist
nämlich sehr speziell aber auch sehr
lecker und danach lassen ihn vollständig
auskühlen
[Musik]
hallo wenn ihr euch wohl etwas da haben
sie auch mit dem video macht wir haben
euch was sehr sehr schönes zu verkünden
wir haben nachwuchs bekommen in der
kirche scream family unsere kokos
kentucky screen coco sich so gewehrt
nicht wiederholten die ist halt kann man
nicht beschreiben man kann nie
beschreiben aber ich würde sagen
probiert sie einfach ganz kurz ganz
ehrlich es gibt keine andere kokos und
sich so heftig ist man sagt mir
irgendwann der mann soll sich nicht
selber loben aber ganz ehrlich wie haben
sie die cocos claim durchprobiert mixed
zunächst nicht
universum heute seine schützlinge
äußerst weil das richtig geld ist
wirklich cool hier bist du so bist
und robert und wird auf jeden fall wird
das natürlich jetzt ein bestandteil
meiner creme ich bin ehrlich das ist so
eine creme löffelrein in den mund oder
aufs brot sowie tolle vision
dieses zeichen limited edition aber
mascha und wenn ihr sie auch so feiert
vielleicht wird es ja keine elemente
zwischen ich sage mal ganz ehrlich wenn
du sagst du morgens keinen kokos du
wirst es trotzdem lieben ist echt so
weil ich muss ehrlich zugibt ich marco
kurz aber ich bin jetzt nicht so leicht
sagt ich mal kokos habe bei der creme
hammer keine worte dafür schlug merken
wo der respekt aber wir
können es ja mal in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr probiert haben wann
was ihr denkt wenn ihr sie probiert ob
wir sind uns dann nämlich bei einer
sache alle einig und die ansonsten haben
danke dass du für die verkündung dabei
war toll für die creme brauchen wir
übrigens auch nur sehr wenige zutaten
allgemein brauchte für dieses rezept
nicht sonderbar viele zutaten ich nehme
jetzt hier sahne die habe ich ganz
frisch aus dem kühlschrank genommen
die ist ganz kalt und ich habe auch
darauf geachtet haben nämlich gerade
mein handrührgerät noch mal sauber
gemacht und man macht sie mit warmen
wasser sauber und ich spüre immer noch
mit kaltem wasser ab damit auch die
jetzt nicht warm sind bin so schlägt
sich die sahne wirklich perfekt auf und
ich werde nach einer halben minute ca
sahne fest einrieseln lassen und dann
komplett steif schlagen
die sache ist jetzt schon steif lege ich
ganz kurz nur zur seite und wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten zutaten wir
brauchen wirklich nicht mehr viel ich
habe hier mascarpone auch schon frisch
aus dem kühlschrank ihr könnt auch
doppel ram frischkäse zum beispiel für
delphi annehmen aber mascarpone mag ich
auch ganz gerne und da gebe ich nur ein
bisschen zucker mit dazu und der ganze
geschmack kommt jetzt durch die chorus
creme und die kokons creme ist auch wie
meine anderen cremes komplett sinnfrei
und natürlich ohne palmöl und auch hier
wieder super cremig deswegen ist so ein
bisschen unser motto so unendlich cremig
und genau so ist die kuppel system auch
wieder gebe ich jetzt auch mit dazu dann
höre ich das ganz kurz um und gibt dann
sahne mit dazu also hab s einfach nur
unter und noch mal ein kleiner hinweis
wenn ihr meine kokos kam auf
zimmertemperatur lagern dann ist es ganz
normal ein fester brotaufstrich wenn ich
für ein paar sekunden die mikrowelle
gibt dann ist es ein fließender
aufstrich mit dem ihr auch wunderbar
kekse verzieren könnt und banken könnt
und im kühlschrank wird die creme dann
aber auch wieder fest dass es so ähnlich
wie bei meinen haselnuss krems und ja
wie gesagt man kann sie auch löffeln
aber ich kann euch auch gerne noch mehr
rezepte damit zeigen und wenn ihr noch
mal rezepte sehen möchte dann schreibt
es mir jetzt gerne in die kommentare
[Musik]
ich habe mir den ausgekühlten nuss boden
jetzt auch einmal durchgeschnitten und
werde mir jetzt von meiner sahne creme
ungefähr ein bisschen weniger als ein
drittel zur seite legen das brauche ich
nämlich später noch für den äußeren rand
und für die decoder zeige ich euch
nachher wie ich das schön dekoriert so
das gebe ich gleich in den kühlschrank
und macht dann weiter mit dem schichten
das heißt ihr nehmt euch schon direkt
eine schöne tortenplatte oder eine serie
platte und könnt dann wenn ihr mögt den
tortenring drum herum legen dann habt
ihr es einfach auf im schicht und beim
verstreichen und dann wird die creme
einfach gleichmäßig verstrichen dann
kommt der zweite boden obendrauf und
schließt gerne auch wieder mit creme ab
damit der boden euch oben auch nicht
austrocknet
[Musik]
wir haben es jetzt gerade den nächsten
tag die torte konnte schön durch kühlen
und ich habe noch ein bisschen was für
die deko vorbereitet ich habe nämlich
kokosraspeln gerüste probierte es
unbedingt mal aus sollte es bringt die
kokosraspeln einfach auch wenn komplett
anderes level es schmeckt viel
intensiver und auch optisch sind die
dann nicht weiß sind ist die torte nicht
komplett weiß sondern habt ihr außen
halt noch so ein bisschen was zum
erfreulicheres und das finde ich
eigentlich ganz süß und wenn ihr jetzt
den tortenring entfernt dann nutzt gerne
ein back for messer ich verlinke euch
sowieso alle utensilien auch unten in
der infobox und fakir einfach so am rand
entlang weil wenn ihr das nicht macht
könnte die gefahr bestehen dass ihr euch
das so ein bisschen wegreißt oder für
mega schade man einfach den tortenring
entfernen dann nehme ich mir schon die
kokosraspeln dekoriere den rand und die
restliche team habe ich mir einen
spritzbeutel getan und wird dann auch
nach oben rum dekorieren
[Musik]
wir probieren jetzt mal dieses
wunderbare prachtstücke sei gespannt auf
seine meinung ich finde ich toll muss
ich würde sagen das mikrofon harmoniert
richtig so mit dem vorjahr das auch
absicht also ist kann nun gestritten
oder
wenn diese krebsform
nachgeschmack bombe war ich habe gedacht
es wirklich ich werde diesen schmeckt
das krasse ist das mal weiß man sich
durch einen extrem lockeren mandl boden
mit dieser superreichen polen streben
diese leichten team und da hat es
gemerkt man kommt es so dieses aromen
habe ich diverse ich kann es gar nicht
sein am ende kommt noch die sagt kick
einfach das richtige ja da hast du
richtig dann den geschmack von der
krise choristen er ist auch wirklich ich
mich richtig wenn heftig zwar nicht zu
schwer im magen der boden doch mal so
was anderes nicht warum genau ich wollte
extra mal was anderes der ist auch
eigentlich ist der komplette brücke
viele leute den freistaat punkten kann
ja und ich habe mir gedacht ich
verzichte einfach auf den und ich
machten richtig locker leicht mandl
boden der einfach zu krebs und es hilft
sich gleich unter den hammer kam ohne
hoch zehn tage sind ich bin dafür dass
nur ein schritt ist der knoten frei ist
weil zu viele leute fragen gemacht haben
so kann das blut in freest und jahres
stimmt das kann ich noch mit dem magix
das ist auf jeden fall gerecht könnt
euch dieses prachtstück leute es
schmeckt heftig und auch gar nicht
fertig oder sona also so total leid ist
noch einmal den ball leider boa heftig
nachmachen ausprobiert bitte zurück zum
video und schreibe es in die kommentare
wie ihr euch geschmeckt hat dass man
nicht wirklich ernst ich möchte dass ihr
genau das gleiche feeling habt wie wir
wenn ihr das probiert also gänzlich war
zum nachmachen wir euch einfach mal
sagen bis zum nächsten video
[Musik]